Hi, this is Presh Talwalkar
Let's discuss an infinite exponential.
Let's say you need to solve for x in the equation:
x, to the power of x, to the power of x, to the power of x infinitely repeated, is equal to 2.
How do you solve it?
If you want to take a stab, pause the video,
otherwise, keep watching for the solution.
The trick is to observe a pattern.
The exponent is x, to the power of x, to the power of x, and so on,
And we know this is equal to 2.
Therefore, we can rewrite the problem as x^2 is equal to 2.
Which then means x is equal to the square root of 2.
I hope you liked this video, please subscribe to my channel,
I make videos on math and game theory.
You can support me on Patreon, catch me on my blog, Mind Your Decisions,
on Twitter @preshtalwalkar, and you can get my books.